what does body positivity mean to you
you know it's interesting because i feel
like it's a term that gets thrown around
a lot and it sort of can be really
simplified and say like love yourself
and that's such a hard goal you know
and i think um body positivity to me
is exactly how we explore it in shrill
which is like
it's kind of this ongoing battle and
it's mostly
internal it's like how can you be kinder
to yourself
and and be uh your own ally
as these external pressures come on to
you and and
you know it certainly changed my life
because i i'd cut myself some slack and
stopped
being so tough on myself and also tried
to stop that constant loop inside your
head of being like oh i shouldn't sit
like this or i shouldn't eat that or i
don't want someone to see me
with my double chin it's like that's my
reality and i actually like myself and
yeah it just makes life a lot better
no i agree i love that definition i'm a
very similar one
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help